why don't you show me what you're
building at adapt AI labs and thanks for
the little diversion down uh history
Lane there super fascinating yeah for
sure so first let me tell you a little
bit more about what we're up to and why
I'm really excited about it and then we
can quickly uh flip through some some
demos of a release we actually recently
did last week the Northstar for depth uh
from day one actually has been that in
the long term the thing that'd be the
most valuable thing to build for work is
an AI agent that uh does much more than
reading and writing and drawing images
but can actually handle for you
arbitrary work tasks and workflows right
and those two things are very different
right like reading and writing is not
the ability for you to say be able to
delegate your entire like payments
process to a neural network in the
latter case what you really want is you
want a system that knows how to use all
the software you already have on your
computer as if it were you and in order
to get there you need to train these
models that uh deeply understand not
just the uh text but also the pixels on
your screen and also what actions lead
to what out outomes in the world and so
we've been hard to work on this training
this model that could do anything a
human can do on a computer and we've
been uh building effectively a product
that enables knowledge workers to
arbitrarily delegate tasks to the system
here's a quick demo example um in this
case uh let's say you're responsible for
paying invoices and you get your
plumbing invoice you fire up a Dept that
pulls up the invoice all being done by
the model right now pulls up the invoice
reads the pixels in this PDF realizes
what it's about stores some interesting
facts about this then pulls up
QuickBooks and then correctly enters who
is the who is the pay right Savant
plumbers like how did you pay um what
what category is this like it realizes
the category was never written in the
PDF but it realizes a plumbing invoice
so it should go into repairs and
maintenance and um this task that you
probably would have had to do like 10 or
20 times a day for your job you show
Adept how to do it once and now every
time you get a new email invoice uh you
just fire up a Dept and it handles this
task for you it's all so where does adep
live is it in your system tray there or
how how does it you intercept this
coming in by via email because you have
this invoice come in via email you got
to get it paid y you're in uh purchasing
uh or accounting boom it needs to know
so how was it just sitting there in the
background running it lives as an
overlay as an extension right now but
we'll soon release a desktop uh overlay
as well and so I think the key of this
is we're not forcing you to use this
brand new system it's a helper for the
same workflows you co-pilot yeah exactly
it's a co-pilot
yeah so it's sitting going to sit in the
system tray but right now it sits in
your browser window your browser window
Y and so you can delegate arbitrary
tasks to it right now I'll show you show
you another example it's actually a
similar variant but like one of the most
common things people do is people
shuttle data back and forth between
system a and system b and a lot of a lot
of knowledge worker jobs is just doing
that like ad nauseum right um we had a
we're talking to some customers who um
their insurance agents have to go log on
to five different software systems to be
able to pull the requisite data to even
get one quote done and so this next
example is one where you get an where
you get an email from uh someone who's
for filing a claim and Adept basically
uh once you show Adept how to do it once
automatically fills out all and
populates all of the forms involved
there you know what's interesting about
about Adept is that it's actually been a
really easy way for us to start working
on this like what I think is going to be
the next battlefield of AI right so far
it's been about llms but I think what's
what's coming up is it's going to be
about multimodality which is the ability
to understand images and it's going to
be about building AI agents because AI
agents as defined as a model that could
take a serious of steps to achieve a
goal is I think fairly clear to
everybody in the field now the thing we
have to get right to get like tremendous
value out of these underlying Smart
Systems yeah so agents uh if we were to
explain them these were like Wizards I
think in the early Windows days you
would create a w you take a you would
create either a wizard or a business
process and all of this is done offshore
business process Outsourcing is a big
part of this yeah people send their
accounting to India they send their data
entry to Manila whatever it happens to
be and this is just taking that same
concept and instead of doing it with
just Brute Force humans uh offshor
millions of them working uh in lower
income or lower cost of living uh
locations the person who's in the US
doing their desktop can just have it
happen in seconds huh it's a really easy
way yeah so our first step as a company
is we've been working on some of these
capabilities that let you as a worker
every day just delegate um these tedious
tasks but where we're really going with
this and what I'm and why uh what I'm
excited about is being able to do
tedious tasks is actually just a
building block for what's even more
valuable which is effectively having an
AI teammate that you can talk to at work
bounce ideas off of each other get
guidance it has the same context as you
do because it's uh it's it it sees all
the same stuff on screen your and uh and
your what you do at your company and all
that stuff and then like help helps you
brainstorm and come up with the best
ideas and maybe try some of them and
you're like well maybe this one's a
little bit better I think all of that
lies on top of a foundation of being
able to do arbitrary things arbitrary
tedious things on your computer close
are you to having how close are you to
having this in Market is this like in
beta somewhere are people using it yet
yeah so um you know what's been
interesting this year is that um is that
the agent space has really suffered from
reliability problems if you go look at
the space as a whole I think there was
an information article about like the
agent winter or something like that it's
because most of these systems the ones
built on top of gpte are like 60%
accurate like they work 60% of the time
one out of 10 times maybe deletes half
your records in Salesforce and you're
like I can't use this at work uh and so
uh with the depth we spent the whole
summer unlike everybody else training
Our Own Foundation models in house that
deeply understand the pixels on screen
are tuned for generating actions and
that took us to a point where this fall
we now have actually very reliable agent
models uh once we have some custom
fine-tuning data per use case so um
we're excited to announce there will be
later uh an announcement about um one of
our really large first deployments but
we also actually last week took
everything we built for our Enterprise
customers cut out the specific
fine-tuning uh that made them their
stuff super accurate and then just made
it into a Sandbox anyone can play with
and so this thing is called adep
experiments you can check it out at ad
dep. aexperimental
um funny thing is actually this morning
uh someone sent me a post on upwork
hiring people who were experts in using
Adept experiments to automate workflows
so it's it's already getting some very
cool attraction on on the agent space
now so the idea is in you're going to
build this platform but we as people
operating businesses will make our own
agents and for ourselves or we're going
to make agents and have the ability to
publish them yeah so our main as a
company um we're actually very
Enterprise focused so we're currently
doing larger engagements where we just
come in and work with our company and
figure out how the Adept agents could
just accelerate the knowledge work
that's happening there but um this
experiments framework that we made is an
is an easy way for you or me or any of
our friends to pick up and just try what
it might be like to go automate
something and then you can publish them
and share them with people like uh CH
GPT is doing H soon yeah we'll soon be
able to let you share uh so far that
didn't quite make the MVP and so that
becomes a business model like an app
store in your mind so if I am uh really
good at accounting I can kind of make
these tools build the classifier engine
for where it should live or whatever and
then publish it to the web and maybe
share Revenue with you is that part of
the model uh it's not the focus of our
model the focus of our model is these
like making Enterprises really
successful but um what's really
interesting about what you just said
though is that like we hope that in an
Enterprise setting you know um
oftentimes like custom knowledge is
locked in some people's brains right
like there's there's one person well at
our company there's like maybe three
people that know how to config this
particular infrastructural dashboard and
they could just teach a Depp how to do
that and just publish that workflow to
everybody at the company so whenever
that needs to be reconfigured you just
hit play on that and and it does it for
you so I'm excited about sharing in that
setting all right you've heard me talk
about arising Ventures a bunch recently
they are a holding company they acquire
Tech startups that uh you know are
facing some headwinds some setbacks and
they give these startups a second chance
at life which is awesome so if you're
going through some tough times right now
and you're trying to get back on solid
footing will reach out to the team at AR
Rising Ventures could be just what your
startup needs to get back on track
they've helped companies like up counil
up Council they took from burning a
million a month and shrinking to
profitable and growing and Jive where
they relaunched a shutdown company went
from Z to 1 million in ARR in just 5
months what a save in fact two saves
listen Rising Ventures knows what
Founders care about because they're not
Bankers they are Tech Founders
themselves and they're here to to help
your startup get back on track learn how
arising Ventures can help give your
company New Life by visiting arising
ventures.com twist today to learn more
and connect with the team that's arising
ventures.com
twist